[Musique]
je suis
ordinaire vrai dire
j'ai fait mes études jusqu'au
baccalauréat dans une région lointaine
mettez les agréables les îles kerkennah
et j'ai débarqué derrière à tunis pour
faire mes études à l'ets hec de carthage
depuis je me suis installé
sans jamais quitter tunis
pour
vivre j'allais dire ma vie
professionnelle
pour faire organiser ma vie de famille
et pour ma vie tout court
on répète souvent autour de moi que je
suis une personne en quelque sorte qui a
réussi brillamment son sac à des
professionnels
c'est vrai au vu de ce que l'entreprise
à laquelle à la création de laquelle
j'ai contribué
il ya
une trentaine d'années
c'est vrai que c'est une c'est un succès
parce que c'est devenu une entreprise
extrêmement performante mais le mérite
revient aussi à mes associés fondateurs
de l'époque aux
associés qui nous aurons le joint tout
au long de ce parcours
est
sans doute aux différentes générations
de collaborateurs qui se sont succédé au
sein de cette entreprise au fil des
années
évidemment
des questions se posent
comment est on arrivé à ce succès
est-ce que c'est pas de chance est-ce
que c'est pas la générosité des acteurs
est-ce que c'est par destin ou tout
simplement par hasard
personnellement je ne saurais vous le
dire
mais
lorsque je me suis livré
il ya quelques jours à cet exercice de
devoir venir vous parler de cette
expérience j'en arrive en fait à
quatre leçons essentielles que j'aurai
le loisir de partager avec vous
moi j'ai démarré mon activité
professionnelle à l'âge de 26 ans et
plus ou moins à la même époque j'avais
commencé une activité sportive nouvelle
pour moi le tennis
savez en général c'est douchy l'enfance
qu'on apprend les bonnes bases du tennis
c'est un sport qui est extrêmement
compliqué à pratiquer mettez les
agréables à jouer
mais bon d'une certaine façon je suis
arrivé à
combler un tant soit peu ce gap et à le
pratiquer d'une façon j'allais dire
continue
à y prendre plaisir
et à le jouer
évidemment sans doute très loin du
niveau professionnel
c'est pas le but mais tout de même je
suis arrivé à de jouer dans des
conditions de compétition
et je réalise en fait
avec ces années là à quel point à la
fois ma pratique de ce sport et mon
exercice professionnel
se sont enrichis mutuellement et
curieusement et à travers cet exercice
là de sortir quelles sont les leçons de
deux de ses plus de 30 années de
carrière
je
jeu conclut je trouve que pas mal de
leçons de vie se croisent
se retrouve au niveau des deux
disciplines
mais avant cela je souhaitais les
d'abord vous parlez de la génèse de
cette entreprise et ensuite on fera
directement un saut de quelques
décennies pour voir
où on en est où elle en est aujourd'hui
vidéo s'il vous plaît
l'histoire a commencé par la rencontre
deux fois jeunes fraîchement diplômés de
liège c'est élisabeth watine l'arabie
jean chérif et nourdine agit il
s'associe aussi avec ali bongo qui a
déjà de l'expérience autour d'un projet
de cabinets professionnels de groupe les
discussions entre ces quatre personnes
ont abouti à la création en mars 1987 de
la société amc audit & management
consulting
hasard parce que en réalité cette
rencontre a été en grande partie le
fruit du hasard
chance parce que c'est une véritable
chance de tomber sur des personnes qu'on
ne connaissait pas assez ou peut-être
pas du tout et puis ça va être le fonds
servant bonne
détermination
parce que nous avons vécu au départ des
moments difficiles mais nous étions
quand même déterminé pour réussir
nous avons toujours pensé nous allons
faire quelque chose de bien
merci
voici là où on est nous sommes
aujourd'hui très clairement le cabinet
professionnel préféré sur le marché avec
la plus grande notoriété et la meilleure
image aussi bien à l'échelle du cabinet
dans son ensemble que celui de ses
différents segments d'activité
avec environ 50 millions de dinars de
chiffre d'affaires et plus de 600
collaborateurs nous nous imposons
aujourd'hui comme le cabinet leaders en
audit et conseil d'entreprise en tunisie
mais également au niveau régional nous
avons ainsi acquis un fort niveau
d'engagement de nos collaborateurs et un
sentiment d'appartenance inégalable
qualifié de best in class dans les
activités de services professionnels
honnêtement non j'étais convaincu que
nous allons réussir en nous faisons une
place respectable mais de là à être un
jour un cabinet référence un cabinet
leader sur le marché non alors what's
next nous mettons déjà le cap sur 2025
avec pour ambition d'être le cabinet de
services professionnels pionnier et le
plus innovant sur le marché le most
langue term value provider pour ses
collaborateurs pour ses clients et pour
la communauté avec un fort rayonnement
au sein de l'espace régional dans son
ensemble
notre ambition est de faire de notre
firme le best place to work sur la place
et la meilleure référence en gender
equality dans la profession notre
objectif est de continuer sur le rythme
de croissance élevé que nous avons
toujours connu pour atteindre à
l'horizon 2025 1000 collaborateurs
produisant plus de 100 millions de
dinars de chiffre d'affaires dans 75 %
réalisés à l'étranger et 40% en service
à haut contenu technologique innovation
et économie verte
[Musique]
merci
alors je sais quoi les quatre leçons de
vie vous avez un peu le vous avez vu le
diable de d'une trentaine d'années je
crois que la plus belle leçon qui me
vient à l'esprit sans doute c'est elle
est la suivante l'ambition et le das
parce que ça commence toujours par un
avoir un succès ça commence par avoir de
l'ambition
ah voilà lève
se fixer au fixés dans son esprit une
image dans laquelle on se projette une
image qui est à la fois extrêmement
positive de soi ou de l'entreprise dans
laquelle on est engagé
et c'est en fait d'une certaine façon de
même chose une image qui est assez
lointaine dans les duels et dans la
durée et une image qui en réalité
complètement en décalage
par rapport à la situation présente
c'est pas possible
évidemment on peut penser que lorsqu'on
se fait se fixe une ambition qui soit
extrêmement j'allais dire positive que
[Musique]
les tellement en décalage par rapport à
la situation présente que avoir ce type
de l'état d'esprit est quelque chose qui
est probablement
improductifs peut-être superflu incongru
non pas du tout je dirais plus l'image
qu'on se met dans l'esprit est
distante par rapport à la situation
présente mieux ça vous
le tout est tout simplement que derrière
cette ambition-là
en aligne des initiatives on aligne les
actions on s'est engag pour parvenir
c'est ça j'allais dire là la clé de
succès évidemment nous nous sommes
passés par là et je crois que c'est
l'une des conditions qui en fait d'une
certaine façon notre succès depuis le
départ et vous allez tout à l'heure voir
cet état d'esprit comment il s'est
répercutée sans le vouloir
à l'ensemble des membres de notre
organisation
alors ça a commencé déjà depuis le
départ et regardez qu'est ce que nous
avons fait à tous nous dit
tout début c'était de faire
1989 c'est à dire deux ans après la
création de notre cabinet alors qu'on
était rien on était quelques personnes
on avait peut-être même pas de
collaborateurs à ce moment-là vidéo s'il
vous plaît
l'histoire de hiva et en tunisie a été
ponctuée de beaucoup de tournants
moments marquants ou des choix
particulièrement audacieux en été
réalisés ce sont ces décisions qui ont
dessiné la trajectoire du cabinet tout
au long de son parcours par exemple en
1990 alors que le cabinet a seulement
deux ans d'existence effective et peine
avec ses quelques collaborateurs à se
faire une place sur le marché les
associés fondateurs décide de partir à
la quête d'un grand réseau international
parmi les big six qui existaient à
l'époque ce qui a abouti à la conclusion
en 1991 d'un accord partenariat avec un
wipe sous le statut de technico grime en
femme
statut qui a évolué après trois ans
d'observation en full member fun
[Musique]
ce sont les anecdotes de philippe aux
offres qui me viennent à l'esprit
philippe a été l'associé qui nous avait
accompagnés tout au long de notre
aventure à aywaille depuis ses débuts en
1990 un jour et nous avait dit je vais
vous faire une confidence légal vous
savez lorsque j'étais venu en 90 pour
faire la cuisine j'ai vu que vous êtes
gentils vous est sympathique mais je me
suis rapidement rendu compte que vous
êtes le petit pas de blancs dossier pas
assez de visibilité sur le marché sans
doute pas le profil que cherche
visuellement et white d'autant plus
qu'il y avait d'autres candidats qui
étaient bien mieux que vous mais
j'avais face à moi des jeunes qui sont
pleines d'ambitions équipe à degrés ils
reconnaissent qu'ils partent de loin
mais affiche une énergie et une volonté
très forte pour aller de l'avant c'est
sûr vous en tant que personne que j'ai
mise et c'est pas sur autre chose
merci donc voilà la première leçon
ambitions audace sans modération à
consommer sans modération
la seconde leçon que je tire de ces
années là c'est qu'évidemment on passe
par des parts des difficultés on passe
par des moments
d'adversité
on ne change par exemple une
réglementation qui change complètement
les règles de jeu un marché qui est
complètement fermée
d'aidé
à l'egypte des situations où des
conditions d'exercice du métier qui qui
qui change radicalement ou que les
conditions du pays deviennent
extrêmement difficile et on en est
passée par là et j'arrive à la fin de
ces années là que finalement dont toute
situation d'adversité
il ya toujours une possibilité de
trouver une voie il ya d'avoir une façon
de contrer cette adversité la comprimer
réaction et deuxièmement de chercher des
opportunités
derrière et oyonnax c'est quelque chose
qui est j'allais dire
et réaliste c'est pas vrai donc la règle
d'or c'est ne jamais cesser de penser
qui a toujours des opportunités dans les
moments d'adversité
parmi les moments qu'on a vu dans ce
coup c'est juste après la révolution je
m'appelle appelé la révolution on savait
2011 2012
notre business a été extrêmement m'ont
touché
nous étions dans une situation flat en
termes d'activité nous avons même
diminué de niveau d'activité et on a
compris que sur le match et tunisiens
selon lesquelles ont été complètement
engagé la situation de mobilité risque
de durer est ce que nous avions fait à
ce moment-là tout simple et sur la
première dès les premiers réflexes
étaient relativement pas pas très bon
mais à la fin on arrive au fait de dire
allez en bas se réinventait on va tout
simplement prendre en compte les besoins
de l'ensemble des marchés qui sont
autour de nous il y avait le volet de la
technologie on s'était dit de toute
façon nous sommes dans un pays où il y a
suffisamment de compétences dans ce
domaine là on va tout simplement
enclenché toute une politique de une
stratégie de développement à
l'international avec couplé avec un
accroissement de l'offre de consulting
autour de la technologie et de 2014 en
été dans une situation faisait à peu
près de 13 millions de dinars de chiffre
d'affaires
0% seul exploit sur
le marché hors tunisie six ans après on
est à la veille de 2011 on est à 50
millions de dinars de chiffre d'affaires
et les têtus est de notre activité
seul international est plus que temps de
poussan de notre activité est out to
knock out
contenu technologique donc c'était ça en
fait le déclenchement et ça s'est pas
arrêté là on a eu la même là même le
même épisode en pleine crise qu vite
parce que tu as récemment cela glisse qu
vite on était engagée sur un plan
d'investissement extrêmement forts
locaux vides étaient venus la première
fois en mars avril 2020 c'était des
situations de crise comment on va faire
il ya beaucoup de millions de dinars qui
sont engagés
la pensée à l'oubli et ben non on a fait
la baisse on a non seulement maintenu
l'investissement on n'a même pas cool le
garder vidéo s'il vous plaît
en 2020 en pleine crise qu vide qui
s'ajoute au contexte politique
économique déjà défavorable les associés
ont décidé d'investir massivement dans
un nouveau cadre de travail et whitehall
alim modernité confort ergonomie et
transitions fluides entre concentration
individuelle et travail collaboratif
[Musique]
le new works style adopté à un white
house est en soi une innovation
aujourd'hui la réservation des espaces
de travail individuel ou collaboratif
les salles de réunion ou des places de
parking se fait via smartphone avec une
priorisation intelligente le paiement
dans le resto interne est également
entièrement digitalisé
iwai towers c'est également la vitrine
d'une orientation forte dans
l'innovation grâce à un espace de 600
mètres carrés dédiés à laboratoire
d'innovation et wye.n station
en station pour dire une région station
en quelques mots c'est un concentré de
compétences dédié à l'innovation leur
mission et d'interagir et d'accompagner
les autres professionnels des services
live les clients et les start up dans
des espaces favorisant la créativité et
la co construction via le design inc
baisser
troisième leçon bien gérer ces moments
de doute dans tout ce parcours nous
avons connu des échecs
j'ai connu personnellement des échecs
j'ai connu et j'ai vécu des moments de
doute pas ton même récemment et au
départ en fait j avais tu es mal cette
situation
je te dis des moments de doute c'est que
par exemple qui perd une grande affaire
dans un processus de deux buildings un
client qui est satisfait parce que l'uck
liés parce que le travail est mal fait
du pèlerin collaborateurs extrêmement
précieux
toi personnellement tu t'engages dans
des réunions internes et finalement tu
te trouves tu as pas été bien inspiré
pour faire avancer les choses on passe
tout ces moments de doute même l'ex
sportif de haut niveau où les les
oliviers de l'aiglon de stars de l'art
du cinéma politique du monde du business
tout le monde connais ces situations-là
est en fait au départ je les gels été
mal donc c'est une période qui qui dure
assez longtemps et je ne sais pas
quelque part je ne sais pas comment les
choses sont enclenchées dans ma tête
c'est à travers le tennis que je me suis
rendu compte qu'en fait qu'il y à une
autre façon de lui de gérer ces moments
là on voyons les grands champions de
tennis qui quelquefois au début d'un
match ne le trouve pas le jeu ils font
tout faux ils sont crispées c'est à
moi dans la même situation je m'énerve
et je perds tous mes moyens et je paye
tout en fait je le garde ses joueurs là
quelles capacités ils ont pour laisser
le temps passait et se dire de toute
façon un moment ou à un autre ça va le
prendre et c'est pas pour ceux qui
connaissent ce sport là et même d'autres
sports comment
une personne arrive à changer
complètement de jeu c'est le 2ème 3ème
4ème jeu vous avez un rude duel federer
qui a fait pas mal ça vous avez un
rafael nadal vous avez c'est quelque
chose d'impressionnant et donc la leçon
que j'avais tiré
lorsqu'on vit des mondes ou de l'île
faut les accepter on n'est pas tous et
tout simplement
essayer de ne pas faire prendre beaucoup
d'initiatives mais surtout ne jamais
perdre de vue dans sa tête quant à un
moment ou un autre le positif pas encore
plantes si la conviction on soit que ça
va redémarrer que ça fait changer les
choses et avec le temps ce moment de
doute aussi maintenant je peux en avoir
mais de toute façon je ne perds jamais
que ça va encore contre et
ktm le sens qu'elle est importante c'est
l'humain
faire de l'humain autour de soi une
véritable force je crois que c'est la
clé du succès de n'importe quelle
organisation qu'elle soit dont
entreprise ou une organisation
donne économique et en cela ce
franchement j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses à travers les années j'ai appris
comment faire en sorte que la diversité
soit une force
évidemment lorsque tout un groupe de
personnes qui sont ensemble pour faire
quelque chose
nous sommes tous des êtres humains nous
avons des atouts nous avons des qualités
mais nous avons des défauts le fait de
le garder de s'appesantir sur les points
faibles de chacun ne fait pas avancer
les choses à coup sûr vous n'avancez pas
en revanche si vous dites que chaque
personne j'oublie un peu ses défauts et
je me concentre sur ses qualités et je
fais de sorte que les qualités des uns
et des autres se mettent en commun vous
fait des miracles ça je l' ai appris à
travers mon exercice professionnel
j'appris également à
écoutez à se donner du temps pour
écouter
lorsque je dis écouter ce n'est pas
uniquement une question de temps parce
que au départ ce que dit écouter écouter
n'importe quelle personne dans
l'organisation quel que soit son âge
quelle que soit sa position quel que
soit son niveau intellectuel je dirais
et
parce que en y pensant
lorsque vous écoutez profondément une
personne souvent vous allez trouver que
ce n'est pas si bête que ça compte
l'institution de vos idées le tout est
que toi même tu change de perspective
par l'apport d'actifs sous 10 et
peut-être de changer donc le de vue par
rapport à ce qui se dit et ça c'est un
élément extrêmement important j'ai
appris également à
exprimer sa reconnaissance envers les
collaborateurs et je me rends compte en
fait que dire merci dire travail bien
fait dire bravo à quel point ça peut
impacter une personne lui donne une
énergie extraordinaire pour aller dire
se surpasser et pour se motiver dans
l'est dans les jours qui suivent c'est
quelque chose qui a un impact
extrêmement fort
tout cela je les ai appris je suis pas
sûr de l'avoir appliqué de façon
correcte
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que je suis
affirmatif en disant que j'ai fait pas
mal de progrès au fil des années dans ce
domaine là et je crois que sur ce
domaine en le faisant d'une façon
continue au sein d'une organisation
il ya quelque part des des valeurs
qu'ils le sortent et qui commence à être
partagée par les alizés de leçons que
vous fassiez un effort quelconque on
appelle ça la culture d'entreprise
on avait posé la question il ya quelques
jours aux membres du comité exécutif les
associés de ce cabinet quelqu'un externe
qui étaient venus les interviewer en le
disant écoute dit moi selon vous quels
sont les deux mots qui traduisent le
plus le mieux votre entreprise le garder
ce crédit vidéo s'il vous plaît
la force de l'humain et l'ambition
ambition ambition ambition et partage
valeurs partagées partage et liqueurs
excellence et partage pas son engagement
accompagné du dehors c'est le timming
équipe et qu'on
est une équipe très engagé où le
dilatoire moule est inédit et de
pragmatisme responsabilités s'épanouir
et se laisse tout une école et une
fierté initiatique ambitions et les wise
on s'est pas du tout concept est donc
voilà le l'histoire de cette petite
entreprise
je voudrais tout simplement le venir à
au tennis ya un vocabulaire
peut-être qu'on ne fait pas attention
mais il est extrêmement instructif
lorsqu'on notamment parle de
d'initiative d'ambition de das
savez lorsqu'un joueur de tennis
en jouant la balle des deux côtés il
frappe la balle et à la croche la bande
du filet là deux hypothèses soit
qu'elles tombent du côté de son camp
évidemment le point contre lui soit
qu'elles tombent du côté du camp de
l'adversaire évidemment il en est
généralement très loin il n'arrive
jamais à les récupérer et les points
effet poule celui qui a fait le coup
du commun des mortels 10 heures il ya eu
de la chance la même chose de ce qu'il
joue une balle il la met sur la ligne
est peut-être elle touche 1 mm il a de
la chance dans le jargon du tennis si
vous faites attention aux mots
commentateurs et dit il a de la réussite
qui part il a de la chance il ya une
nuance
cela signifie que si chance il faut
parce que tu as un joueur qui a provoqué
cette chance si lui qui a frappé la
balle c'est lui qui a pris l'initiative
de la frappe est du côté de la ligne le
plus loin possible de du joueur est là
toute la nuance alors il n'y a qu'à vous
souhaitez vous l'avez compris je vais
pas vous dire le bonne chance mais votre
réussite merci
[Applaudissements]